thank you
[Music]
guys ready for something that is going
to be known as the old Spanish loophole
Spanish are we talking about Shakira
whoa
dude that's crazy what's Shakira do
she's a loophole she's going through
like uh she's red flag right now by the
IRS all right of Spain oh yeah oh she's
Spanish yeah I was Spain from 2012 to
2014 apparently tax evasion around 24
million dollars worth of income or
something like that holy [ __ ] but she's
she's contesting it because she's like
numb I [ __ ] do all [ __ ] the right way
so it's gonna go to court okay well I
mean maybe the person she assigned to do
it the right way didn't do it the right
way she's like it's not just my hips
that don't lie I'm talking I'm talking
about I'm talking about me as well
I understand that that's not the article
though so where are we going all right
so you got this guy he's a worker in
Spain he works in some office gets
pretty uh gets pretty upset with his
bosses and his co-workers decides to
shoot the place up oh my God wow
straight to that huh shoot takes out
three of his co-workers a cop comes in
tries to arrest him shoots that cop no
fatalities though he sucks at shooting
the coffee yeah it's all all ankle shots
target practice the cop that finally
takes him down actually shoots him and
paralyzes him so now this guy's a
paraplegic he's gonna face his charges
the court tells him hey there's one way
that you can avoid all charges and
that's if you legally kill yourself
last year they changed the law where in
Spain you you're allowed the right to
euthanasia
wait self use euthanasia but you have to
have a condition or be in some physical
uh constraint that makes it difficult or
like painful to live but which he does
qualify but isn't he handy capable
like isn't that isn't this actually kind
of power
Waters wait can we um I don't know if
the information is there but can we like
weigh out his decision like what are his
charges or what is he up to face versus
uh killing himself yeah they're pretty
bad Chargers because he shot a cop first
of all even just that dude he's done
he's done for Life yeah but he's also
already a paraplegic I think it's life
in prison as a paraplegic or death
either which one seems easier the the
crazy thing is it's a race right now
because they're trying to this decision
is under appeal like it's under review
whether or not he should be able to do
this because the families are the people
he shot and demand real Justice they
don't want him to kill himself yeah
that's what I was thinking they
shouldn't give them that option like
make them but nobody died you said
nobody died or make them stay alive yeah
if nobody died and the other people like
they're not like uh are they are they in
similar like paraplegic type of
conditions or I don't believe anybody
else is a paraplegic but they are just
they have to have but that bullet woman
must have hurt though yeah because every
time they're like [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
man make that [ __ ] suffer I don't even
know you can get guns in Spain like that
uh you can get guns everywhere but if
it's illegal how did they get it yeah
like what's the gun laws because gun
laws really work that's fine they do
work they do work part
they're taking siestas all the time just
like they do in Italy you know they're
having sex all the time I mean he his
own personal gripe was that he was being
like verbally abused at work and then
everyone just making them feel like [ __ ]
so he just snapped he's like I tried to
do my shooting on the up and up yeah and
now here I am and I'm in a wheelchair
I'm just trying to shoot their ankles
just uh you know piss them off a little
bit Yeah he was like man they only give
us two hour lunch breaks here can you
believe it
everyone gets my [ __ ] Uncle marsupial
gets [ __ ] four hours out of curiosity
what what would you guys do he's like so
we only get a 30 minute grace period too
it's a Spanish name marsupial you know I
can only imagine jail here because I
don't know what Jail's like over there
but they're pretty sweet if I'm a
paraplegic and I know I have to be in
jail for the rest of my life I'd
probably go the euthanasia route if I
don't have kids is there like a window
at which she's allowed to choose choose
euthanasia or like for example can he be
like all right I'm just gonna go to jail
and then like you know years later he's
like this sucks balls yeah I think there
is or you could test it I think that's
why you should have to make a hot
decision in the moment yeah that's what
they're determining affects everything
is uh I think once that chance is missed
for him to decide that's like you're you
just gotta go
all you fans out there in the comments
give us your answer because that is a
very very complex human position but
then it depends what place you're
looking at it from like if you're let's
say that that happened to your mom right
she got shot and then the guy who shot
your mom now is parabolic when the cops
stopping him do you want to see him live
out a sentence in pain and misery or
like do you not give a [ __ ] if you just
die it depends if he's very optimistic
like for me like let's say if that
happened to me I'm like yes I could
think of a good comeback story or I do
my time in prison I'm paraplegic and I'm
gonna write a book and I'm like I'm
thinking about like doing a tour and
then maybe like I [ __ ] help other
paraplegic jail people and then like at
the end of it like I'm gonna be a
[ __ ] star and then I'm just gonna
like benefit off of my crime I committed
and then I'm like if it's that kind of
[ __ ] I want them to die also I
don't know how different it is in Spain
but if this was America and someone
kills themselves no civil suit so you
can't get any money out of them hey Ryan
can we see a Google image of a Spanish
because the way that I'm thinking
Spanish jail yeah the way that I'm
thinking about it is if I go to jail and
I'm a paraplegic my butthole's done why
because you wouldn't feel it no that's
the thing they're gonna everyone's like
bro you're not even well feel it yeah
let me get it I don't wanna and then I
can't even move and they just [ __ ]
manhandle me but why do you care then
you won't even be ashamed I will be
ashamed because I still got my [ __ ]
brain I'm still like I can still go oh
what the [ __ ] I don't know because
because you'll feel your wheelchair
rattling around they're messing up your
wheelchair cushions
yeah why do they all look the same yeah
I think they just build jails the same
yeah they got to make their own flavors
I think I think I choose the euthanasia
typing Japanese jail that doesn't look
like wrong why isn't there any
culturalism yeah it just [ __ ] Flags
everywhere like Bulls
right they should have like like
hieroglyphics yeah it's like cops are
walking around handy on Tapas everybody
that's what they need they should have a
fruit guy he's like he's like I don't
get any business why do I show up here
it sucks do you think they get a siesta
in prison it's Spain dude yeah they
probably do right yeah it's inhumane to
not get a siesta in Spain I think our
ball runs through there too yeah yeah
they do bull runs for sure I would
assume that most people uh
would be afraid to off themselves
regardless of the situation that's true
like but they're probably gonna get
injected to like Dr Kevorkian office or
something what are you gonna do I think
if I were to honestly honestly put my
hot decision you can't [ __ ] go yeah
honestly I think to put myself in a
decision I don't think I would at that
moment have the balls to be like yeah
off me because of the charges yeah you
know what I mean you're paraplegic yeah
you're also in like horrible pain yeah
you know what the kind of [ __ ]
are in jail they sneak [ __ ] guns in
their buttholes what about Spanish jail
though [ __ ] are crazy it might
be different in Spanish you have a very
clear answer you kill yourself yes
because Japanese jail yeah see I told
you it's different I hung around okay
Japanese jail that looks like a horse
stable yeah you know all the
[ __ ] that big herc talks about
yeah [ __ ] are crazy and if
they're if a hot female guard is walking
by and they're always saying that's how
you gun them down they're all the dudes
are jacking off they don't even care
looking at each other's dicks and stuff
[ __ ] are crazy
they try to admit or just or they're
sneaking cell phones in their ass
[ __ ] cigarettes and [ __ ] like just
the type of this you're in a wheelchair
and they're gonna make you watch I don't
even know what side I'm on but this is
great bring it on [ __ ]
they're gonna make you sit there every
[ __ ] day and watch kids just lose the
quest every [ __ ] single day so I get
to watch Quest this is my favorites
a rerun
do you want to live
so far that's not that bad
Jesus Christ he's talking about getting
[ __ ] thrown around like a ragdoll
getting raped in the [ __ ] everything
no and you're gonna be used as a
messenger of some sort no no no I'm
gonna be a Pawn Yeah but at least at
least they put the brakes on Bart's
wheelchair before they rape his ass so
it doesn't jibble around you but also if
you're in a wheelchair you could
probably fit and you can't fit me feel
anything in your butthole you could
probably fit all kinds of stuff you're
gonna be the new mule Bart will be the
new the newest pocket in the deepest
pocket it's called the prism he might
find purpose it seems pretty redundant
though like let's say you did want to do
like a mass shooting in your workplace
you've probably already prepared the die
by cop that's true so if you're gonna
like get caught dying doesn't seem like
much of a looming threat it's like yeah
I would have died anyway but you shot me
in the C5 that's the legislation anybody
who chooses [ __ ] euthanasia on the
back end they're like we're gonna put
your ass in jail for life
that's tight it's just always the
opposite yo oh that's good actually
that's really good that's good man you
see you see I'm [ __ ] up you gotta
figure it out I like that they should do
like Wheel of Fortune type uh
punishments where you don't even know
you just go [ __ ]
yeah but it always lands on jail every
time but then but then when the guy's
like yes you're like
no
[Music]